Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie we have a
brand new first look at the Venom 3 movie so
we'll break it all down they've started filming
and obviously there's a whole bunch of stuff going
on in the Spider-Man universe of movies the Sony
spin-off movies are doing in the Venom universe
as well as Tom Holland Spider-Man in the MCU
with Spider-Man 4. in the new Trilogy that he's
working on and they also just had that live-action
crossover scene with Venom in Spider-Man across
the spider verse what do you want I'm robbing you
because I'm a bad guy if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we just got the Kraven the hunter trailer I did a
video for that so I'll link it at the end of this
but we're starting to see the movies reference
Spider-Man more and more I think that the best
example is still the morbius trailers even though
they cut a lot of that out of the movie there was
so much Spider-Man in that movie you could just
feel Kevin feige telling them behind the scenes
please take all that Spider-Man out we don't want
to ruin Spider-Man no way home is doing so well
at the box office but during the footage you see
them filming a new Venom 3 scene with Eddie in Los
Mateos Spain what might be going on here is they
might just be filming in in Spain and it might be
doubling for Mexico and he's still in Mexico after
the events of the last movie during the movie he's
meant to be on the Run since the end of Venom Let
There Be Carnage in the Spider-Man no way home
post credit scene so at the end of Venom Let There
Be Carnage Chief led the United States to Mexico
that's where the hotel room the seat on the beach
were supposed to be and then he was transported to
the MCU Universe version the hotel room by Doctor
Strange's first spell during the Spider-Man no
way home post credit scene he just walked from
that room with the very surprise random dude
to the Hotel bar getting super drunk talking to
Christo Fernandez the bartender about everything
that happened in the MC up to that point like they
recapped the events at the MCU through Avengers
Infinity War Avengers end game with Thanos the
snap even Tom Holland Spider-Man most people
remember him as Danny Rojas from Ted lasso the
fact that they were talking about Spider-Man
is a little bit funny because obviously it's
venom so they want Venom to be thinking about
Spider-Man like he was on his way to New York
City to talk to Spider-Man as if they were going
to face each other before Doctor Strange's second
spell transported him back to his Venom Universe
right now the rumor about the plot is that the
real main villain of the movie is actually going
to be a version of the xenophage which is a race
of cultures in the Marvel Comics that feed
off the Symbiotes like natural predators to
the Symbiotes and for the most part the only real
natural predator that symbiotes is actually no God
of Symbiotes they're meant to be apex predators
so someone they could actually take them down is
meant to be really really powerful there have been
a couple deleted scenes and a couple references to
Knoll but obviously Noah isn't going to be a
big character during Phantom 3. he'd be like
an end game Thanos level threat for the Venom
characters they wouldn't go straight to that in
a Trilogy you say that for like some giant huge
Universe crossover the report right now is that
during the movie The xenophage won't be from
another planet like the symbios as it is in the
comics it'll be the result of the government's
genetic experimentation on the Symbiotes in the
previous movies to create their own anti-venom
type of symbiote weapon but it won't literally
be Anti-Venom from the comics which is like
a totally different character anti-venom was
created when Eddie Brock had separated from the
Venom symbiote briefly it left traces of the
Symbian out in his body he developed cancer and
then went to one of Martin Lee's Feast shelters
for help which they featured in the Spider-Man
games they even featured Aunt May's Feast
shelters during Spider-Man no way home briefly
while Eddie Brock was there Martin Lee used his
Mr negative powers to cure Eddie's cancer but
the process also caused the Symbiote traces in
his body to change and bond with his white blood
cells creating a new hybrid anti-venom symbiote
it manifested fully for the first time when
the regular Venom symbiote tried to bond with
his body again all of its powers as you'd expect
were mostly healing based in addition to regular
enhanced attributes that all symbiotes give people
it can cure any disease any impurity in his body
or other people's bodies and it's completely
mindless unlike the regular symbiotes so when
Eddie Brock is wearing the anti-venom symbiote
he's fully in control they might eventually have
some Easter eggs for anti-venom in the Venom
movies but I don't think they have any plans
to completely separate Eddie Brock permanently or
semi-permanently from the Venom symbiote they've
already done the symbi a body swapping trick a
couple times in the movies like with Anne Wang
lady Venom there are also rumors that Patrick
Mulligan will return as a version of toxin as
a lot of people assumed after Venom let them be
Carnage because of the ending with his character
foreign ers
he got the toxin symbiote as a result of their
final fight reportedly that character will go
on to become another anti-hero symbiote like
talks and does in the comics and he and Venom
will have to team up to stop xenophage who will be
the True Villain of the movie and after that toxin
would just go on to continue being an anti-hero
in the universe on his own which is pretty much
how things go in the comics but toxins history
is these are relatively new character he wasn't
introduced till 2004 during a Venom vs Carnage
storyline so Circle of Life the Carnage symbiote
realizes that it had been pregnant and was about
to spawn another symbiote but it hated the idea of
toxin before it was ever born because it was this
prophecy that the thousandth iteration of their
lineage the toxin symbiote would become way more
powerful than any of them before so Carnage hates
the idea of toxin even more than it hates Venom
what a happy family because you have to remember
that Venom is kind of like toxin's grandfather it
made a plan to kill toxin as soon as it spawned
so it's like killing your child right after it's
born but the spawning process left him so weak
that he couldn't do anything about it but because
Patrick Mulligan just happens to be nearby it puts
the toxin symbiote into him as sort of a temporary
holding vessel saying that he'll come back when
he regains his strength to kill both of them so
Carnage didn't give Mulligan the toxin symbiote
because he cared about him or he trusted him he
was using him more like a tool like a plaything
then when Carnage does become strong enough a
bunch of other characters stop him from killing
toxin Venom actually stops him hoping that he can
train toxin to fight Spider-Man and Carnage he's
also responsible for naming the new symbiotoxin
he calls him toxin because his symbiote smells
poisonous to the other symbiotes but he has all
their abilities just turned up to 11 so he can
do all the same things that Carnage can do that
Venom can do but just more later it's revealed
that Mulligan has a strong enough personality and
sense of morality to show carnage Mercy when they
fight so Venom and Carnage then realize that it's
possible toxin could eventually turn good and team
up with Spider-Man against them which obviously
they don't want so then Venom and Carnage try to
team up to kill toxin like I said those three
symbiotes relationship is very complicated
eventually Peter Parker Spider-Man does help
toxin during the fight realizing what's going
on and then gives Mulligan the same version of
the Uncle Ben speech with great power comes great
responsibility in Mulligan walks away spending
his early days as talks and trying to teach the
Symbiote how to be good it's a little bit what you
saw at the end of the first Venom movie with Eddie
trying to teach the Venom symbiote how to be good
Sony also has several other Spider-Man spin-off
movies that they're either finished filming or
they're in the middle of filming or they plan on
filming all them are meant to take place inside
the same Venom universe but the real crossover
movie that they're building up to at least right
now in the background is still supposed to be the
Sinister sixth movie with Michael Keaton's a
vulture and they continue introducing more of
the core Sinister Six villain characters in the
universe I just did a kraven the hunter trailer
video the Kraven movie is one example of that but
the difference a lot of people have been asking
about since the Kraven trailer came out is that
most of those villains are being introduced as
anti Heroes like they want to make venom seem like
a good character they want to make Kraven seem
like more of a good character so it sounds like
there's going to be some kind of twist on their
character where the Sinister Six come together but
not all of them really want to kill Spider-Man the
same way and supposedly Sony is trying to set
up their Sinister Six movie with them facing
Tom Hall's Spider-Man because everybody's been
wondering who is the Spider-Man that they keep
referencing in all these movies but supposedly the
Sinister Six movie wouldn't be part of the new Tom
Holland Spider-Man 4 MCU Trilogy it wouldn't
be one of those sequels it would be like Sony
doing their own thing with a Sinister Six movie
borrowing Tom Holland inside the Venom universe
and then he'd go back to his MCU Spider-Man
solo Trilogy based on the timing for when all
these movies are currently being released Sony
is probably going to try and do that Sinister
Six movie before Tom Holland Spider-Man 6. I
believe Marvel is going to try and finish that
by 2029 or 2030 depending on how many delays there
wind up being between now and then it's still a
long time and for those of you that want to see
Andrew Garfield come back is Amazing Spider-Man
reportedly Sony also tried to get him to come
back as his Spider-Man for the Sinister Six
movie instead of doing Tom Hall and Spider-Man
but he turned them down at the time that could
always change separately Sony also does have plans
to introduce their own new Spider-Man inside the
Venom universe so that they can use the character
more regularly and Tom Holland doesn't have to do
a billion movies because he's not going to do that
and they can't force him to do that supposedly the
plan originally was for them to actually say that
the Venom Universe really was Andrew Garfield's
Amazing Spider-Man universe I've talked about this
in previous videos because there's so many Easter
eggs that pointed to that like they really wanted
it to be Andrew Garfield's universe and they were
planning on having his character retire so to
speak so that the other new Spider-Man that they
introduced could take over day to day they also
separately just confirmed that doing a live-action
Miles Morales movie soon they also had that big
crossover in Spider-Man across the spider-verse
so they've already canonized the version of
this Miles Morales to the larger Venom universe
they could always wind up using the same
Miles Morales twist as they do in his animated
spider-verse movies and just not kill off Andrew
Garfield's Peter Parker they could just say that
live action Miles Morales just comes from Andrew
Garfield's universe and becomes the day-to-day
active Spider-Man that way Andrew Garfield
can come back in Cameo as Spider-Man every
once in a while because they're all supposed
to come back like Tobey Maguire pretty much
all the fox characters are coming back at some
point during Avengers 6 Secret Wars let me know
in the comments though if Sony does wind up
introducing a brand new version of Spider-Man
for their movies which version of Spider-Man
do you want it to be and who do you want to
be that character secret Invasion episodes have
started my full secret Invasion Episode 2 video
will post Wednesday just like normal be sure to
enable alerts for my channel so you don't miss
that they also just released the Five Nights
at Freddy's trailer I might do a video for
that links for my Kraven the hunter trailer
video down in the description below you can
click here for my new secret Invasion Episode
2 video I'll update the link as soon as I post
that and click here to learn about Ben Affleck
coming back as his Daredevil in Deadpool 3
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!